and interests you play British and we've
heard your American accent few times
Chris what do you watch the wire oh I
love the wire did you know that a dress
was British not at all he scared the
out of me right now
nobody knew you were pretty yeah no I
mean bet the truth is a broad ition for
this for so long and they told me you
know don't come in with your English
accent it doesn't sound very some of the
great young New York and I saw you in
the lobby I would just turn around your
American accent has not always been that
good for you right now I don't know
what's go you do the science of genetic
space precinct 934 oh yeah 1990 94
did you never seen well no I've heard
that there's a clip of it and I had a
quick look on YouTube they they dubbed
my voice all right it's not me it's
actually didn't even do a really good
American accent Eva okay they don't
sound like me have you ever got a clip
you've been doing oh so so this this is
Idris but very suckling it's beautifully
done the dubbing you may not even notice
that it's non-interest speaking
cops are you involved with the police or
to me not to worry dog you just
concentrate on doing what you do best
being beautiful sublight pizza time
between the bay hot delivery anywhere on
out our guarantee
[Applause]
[Music]
you